former goldman ceo lloyd blankfein he
loves bitcoin and cryptocurrency well
kinda so ultimately we know that lloyd
was the ceo of goldman sachs from 2004
2006. he then took over as ceo in 2006
all the way through 2018. you may
remember him and know about him because
of the global financial crisis he had a
big hand in terms of talking uh to the
media and talking through a lot of the
events that were happening during that
global financial crisis but ultimately
he still is heavily involved in the
financial system he's seen as an advisor
he still has a lot of investments in the
market so people want to know what does
the former ceo of goldman sachs think
about bitcoin cryptocurrencies
historically he hasn't been that big of
a supporter he seemed to kind of be a
skeptic but now all of a sudden here we
go he's on board lloyd said quote my
view of it is evolving i can't predict
the future but i think it's a big thing
to be able to predict the present like
what is happening and i look at the
crypto and it is happening that ends up
being a very important and big deal is
when you get the former ceo of goldman
sachs now saying listen regardless of
what i think or anybody else thinks in
the market bitcoin cryptocurrencies this
is happening i'm watching it happen and
so therefore he now acknowledges it
we've got a video that will play here in
a minute in terms of exactly what he was
saying but it's important to remember
that even the banks are getting involved
as well there's all kinds of traditional
banks or investment banks like goldman
that have been offering clients ways to
buy trade and custody digital currencies
but ultimately what we know is that
these leaders these advisors the people
who have been running these
organizations for long periods of times
the noise has gotten too loud they can't
ignore it anymore and so here's blank
fine exactly what he said the other day
pragmatist and somebody who's skeptical
not only of the market but skeptical of
my own views and trying to
get on board and acknowledge things that
i don't know everything and strange
things things that i think are strange
actually happen i'd say at the point now
it's lost a lot of value but a point
where it's trillions of dollars of value
contributing to it and the whole
ecosystems are growing around it and of
course we have the benefits of
instantaneous transfer and so a
reduction of credit risk and all the
benefits of blockchain that a million
people come on your show and talk about
i'm uh you know i may be skeptical but
i'm also uh pragmatic about it and so
guess what i would i would want to have
it i certainly want to have an ore in
that water pretty incredible when you
look at the fact that he's not only
saying listen i used to be skeptical but
i still want to have an ore in the water
what he's talking about there is he
wants to have a horse in the race
whatever words whatever phrases you want
to use it's very very telling that the
former ceo of goldman sachs now he likes
the stuff he's going to invest he's
going to make sure he has financial
exposure to an asset that has grown as a
market to over a trillion dollars now of
course he's also worried about inflation
and many other parts of the legacy
system and so one of the big questions
and one of the big things to watch is
how many of these executives are
actually going to be running towards
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies versus
they're simply moving because they're
running away from what's happening in
the legacy market regardless of why
they're coming they are all on the way
some of them are here some of them are
running towards it some of them are
running away from the legacy system but
every single one of these people will
capitulate every single skeptic every
single one of them eventually realizes
it's too big to ignore what do you guys
think
well it is the perfect example from
someone who went as a skeptic learned
about the technology and now is becoming
more and more interested in it he was
originally skeptical about it because it
was new technology he didn't really know
the use cases of it um but after looking
into it he clearly understands that
crypto is here to stay there's trillions
of dollars flowing into the asset
so i like that he changed his mind i
like that he's open-minded and he's
obviously very smart right he went to
harvard he went to harvard law he's a
former goldman ceo um
also the former goldman c-o-o so he kind
of knows what he's talking about um and
i like to see him on the side of crypto